Americans recycle about 66 million tons
of material each year according to the
EPA that sounds like a lot during the
holiday period from Thanksgiving to the
new year Americans throw away about 25%
more trash than at any other time that
includes boxes wrapping paper gift bows
and Christmas trees now if every family
in the US wrapped just three presence in
reused material it could save enough
wrapping paper to cover 45,000 football
fields Charice jones is USA TODAY's
business and retail reporter Charisse
good morning good morning what is going
on with Americans when it comes to
recycling Europeans do it a lot better
than us why can't we catch up you know
we're recycling a lot more but we're
just not that good at it you know in the
olden days it was mainly stores and
businesses that had to deal with excess
paper and boxes and now it's us you know
ordinary homeowners and apartment
dwellers we're ordering online Amazon
strapping a billion boxes on our
doorsteps and we just don't know what to
do with it and it's causing a real
problem for our community it's confusing
though especially the things you're
talking about with wrapping paper and
bows can wrapping paper be recycled what
do you have to look for it can if it's
plain paper but if it's got any
embellishment you know like glitter or a
beating or anything like that
right you want the fancy stuff but you
know what really good idea is just to
use gift bags and then the person you're
giving you to can reuse it for their
lunch and for other holidays that's kind
of a safer way to go raise your hand if
you've reused gift what about the bows
then what about recycling those but
those are not great they usually contain
plastic and they've got that sticky
stuff on the back so that's not good for
recycling and so it's really best to
just reuse them put a little piece of
tape on them and just use them holiday
after holiday and then when they're done
just put them in the garbage can there's
a structural issue here right - because
that China used to take a lot of these
boxes and they're not anymore right you
know because our recyclables were so
contaminated like 25% of the stuff we
put in these bins shouldn't be there
like the greasy pizza box and the milk
carton that's half full so they don't
want that
stuff and that's what's causing a lot of
the problems it's towns don't have to
pay a lot more to get rid of it and we
need a PhD we need a PhD to figure out
what goes where exactly it's a recycling
nut in my house so I'm like are you
gonna recycle that I hope you are for
take-out delivery containers should
people wash those too then recycle or is
that considered contaminated - like the
greasy boxes if you rinse it out it's
usually fine but if there's something
that you can't quite get off it's best
to just throw that in the garbage
otherwise it causes a problem in those
bins holiday cards I'm thinking I know
I'm stuck on all that but like the cards
you get so many of them some are glossy
some aren't can those papers yeah the
glossy is not good plain paper is great
but if you're printing it out yourself
on your home printer that's not a good
thing I mean I really think ecards are
great I mean I know we love the
mantelpiece that's covered with car just
people just to be clear send a card to
me it's you know but if you send the e
cards your loved one knows you're
thinking about them you save the postage
you don't have to worry about all that
excess paint you could also use recycled
material though to send those cards
right exactly if it's plain paper or
recyclable material it's fine but if
it's the glossy stuff or it's got the
glitter on it forget it are there
sustainable brands that you would
recommend brands for wrapping paper or
for ribbons well you know you can go to
the Environmental Working Group they've
got a website and they talk about
products that are really good to use
there's done good which tells you about
different things that are eco conscious
and socially conscious so they can kind
of give you a guide as to what you need
to do along those lines and what you
need to do you're saying you're you know
you recycle everything I try I get
confused
are we getting better I mean do we
really want to do this here or are we
just bad at your the rates going in the
right direction ya know so be millenials
and generations II love to recycle
they're very into sustainable products
companies that do the right thing so
it's becoming very popular and at this
point everything from sneakers to makeup
comes in a sustainable form so you can
find something that you're looking for I
got to get better at it don't send a
Christmas card and it's gonna rain I
know Theresa thank you so much